hello there
reject nation I'm Greg OPA and I'm John
Humphrey I want to thank Skillshare for
sponsoring this what Skillshare not
sponsored by Skillshare Oh every
youtuber I watched has been sponsored by
Skillshare lately I thought we were too
what gives I not that I know
well then download and follow us on the
Stardust app over there we do 30 second
reaction reviews for any film TV show
and/or trailer we post daily oftentimes
if we do movie reviews we post there
first it's free to download free to use
follow us first let's talk about John
wick chapter 3 Parabellum the longest
title in this fridge it's got two
subtitles well john would you think of
the movie i like this movie a lot
nothing quite reaches the highs of the
first movie still to me but i mean the
action is super impressive i think this
is definitely my second favorite keanu
performance out of the franchise even
though there are some moments where i
got a little too big for me it's still
just an incredibly well realized action
world that they've created i probably
making it number two in terms of the
John wick franchise right now there we
go one three two goes without saying
that it's gonna be insane we all know
that I love how the trailers for the
John wick movies can never ever show you
just how truly crazy the actions gonna
get and in this movie especially as
being an action fanatic I really love
the heights they took it to here it's
when you go into a John wick film which
are primarily gonna be looking out for
there's a lot of the gung foo a lot of
gun play action and while you get plenty
of that in here I was really impressed
with the hand-to-hand combat yeah
because the director chasse to hell ski
who originally worked on the Matrix
films that trilogy is primarily known
but in terms of action for its kung-fu
and then there's some gun action in
there then this movie franchise it's
primarily known for the gunplay and then
in this one they're bringing a lot of
it's a very modern day brutal
hand-to-hand combat really early on in
this movie when you start getting into
the action scenes the whole
crowd was participating I believe the
two first big heights earned a
well-deserved round of applause from the
entire theater also say this the action
not go fast this film but it's
definitely more gory than the first two
there's a lot more just to the
ramifications and having the top of your
head shot off for example yeah that's
just one example I don't want to give
any specifics away because I don't want
you to be on the lookout for it but be
aware that there's gonna be moments
where me participating with the crowd
going oh oh
there's a lot of gross stuff better
years way more than the first two yeah
this movie is brutal and I think that
first and foremost I mean if you're a
fan of action movie cinema if you're a
fan of great stunt work I mean this this
movie is definitely gonna be something
that you'll love because part of the
charm what I've realized over time is
especially between David leach isn't
involved anymore but you know between
him and has Dallas Key these are two
guys who have a stunt background but who
also have directing second unit acting
backgrounds as well and this is a series
that has done a really good job of
paying attention to all those things to
back up the action and this movie on an
action front does what all good action
franchises arguably do which is bringing
more and more kinds of fight scenes more
and more kinds of weapons I mean there's
an incredible knife fight in this movie
there is a pretty wild dog fight in this
movie they see it seizing the trailer
they feel straight out of like you're
playing a video game yeah used that
phrase for several action scenes
throughout this whole franchise but that
fight in particular was like oh man it
is like what playing a video game where
you have like a little helper yeah it's
it's really well shot I love how they
keep these angles primarily in the wide
that way you could really watch the
performers go to work you don't feel
that they're heavily relying on editing
in order to make any of the action
scenes work no so much of this is done
in like one big shot or very clear shots
with very clear movement yet the moments
really play out I think the action in
this specific movie is probably the best
out of any of the film's best conceived
yet yeah in terms of choreography in
terms of how they
utilize the camera work I think it's the
best I don't think this film is by any
means perfect but there's some other
great additions that are in this film
before we go into some of the criticisms
as Mark Dacascos oh yeah as the villain
in this movie wonderful
my favorite villain out of this whole
franchise ie I believe makes an
impression it's like yeah we if you're
familiar of Mark Dacascos you're like
he's gonna be cool the action and he
sure is has some wonderful wonderful
fight sequences but they really made him
a character here with a real personality
you know outdoing too much away he gets
probably the biggest laughs in this
movie yeah yeah and I thought that was a
fun wait like there's the phrase hurting
expectations gets thrown around a lot
lately but I do think that yeah he is
probably my favorite villain of the
series partly because there are some
surprises about his character you
wouldn't necessarily see coming and
they're not the standard of a hitman
movie and I think that this movie
overall with its characters does a fun
job especially in the guys that John is
fighting making those guys kind of human
and kind of part of a community together
you know and what just hit me now
another reason why I love his villain is
because it's an actual villain that
poses an equal threat to John wick Keanu
Reeves is once again
great this role is perfect for him they
can state that enough Halle Berry I feel
like she might get overall a very
positive response they're all
distinguished for a character by two
ways her performance as this character
Sophia I thought she did a good job
sometimes feel like Halle Berry is
always trying to win an Oscar which can
sort of pull me out a little bit like
she gives it her all she gives it her
a-game
sometimes it comes across like she's
acting for a heavier movie or something
yeah yeah she's still really good the
way she does her fight scenes she
delivers you could tell that she was
very very well trained for this that
fight with her and Keanu and the dogs is
one of the most memorable fights out of
this whole movie my one little criticism
about the way she fights in here and I I
don't feel like most people are gonna
notice this I think when I even said
this year after the movie was done I was
like this is probably just a Greg thing
when she's fighting especially cuz
you'll cut back and forth between her
and Keanu
when she fights it feels very neat it
feels very choreographed oh she's
definitely
trained her she's moving great but
there's a lack of emotional intensity
behind her when she's moving as opposed
to when you cut to Keyon it was like and
that's the way it was for every fighter
in this movie you can feel the
performance in the fight with her I felt
that choreography was nailed and she
nailed that but there was a missing
element of a performance when she's
fighting and that's it's really just a
nitpick but that's like my one little
criticism towards were there it's got
also just a lot of great supporting
actors like Angelica Houston is terrific
I really like Asia Kate Dillon who
played the adjudicator a lot like of the
high table Lance Reddick of Asia wrong
because yeah yeah yeah he gets some real
shining moments in this movie but in
terms of going into the movie of some
actual issues I had with it I think the
first 20 to 30 minutes of this movie is
the best part of this felt it picks up
immediately after the events of John
wick to there's a contract out on his
head and that you know like at a certain
time 6 p.m. is what they establish in
this movie anyone who's an assassin in
New York just free to try and kill John
wick that first chunk of the movie was
so well done felt personal felt intent
it hearkened back to mean to the first
John wick yeah where you could feel the
paranoia yeah every time he's killing
someone you're like Joe it's more than
just oh cool you know like you have that
and that's why I love the first John
wick so much because when he's killing
people you feel for John wick as he's
doing it as opposed to most of Part 2
for me which is like that was badass
oh that's really cool but you don't
really feel that wait in the first 20 to
30 minutes of this you really feel that
weight amidst the unique choreography
after that the movie starts having some
pacing and story issues I still really
like it
every action scene that comes up is
still amazing movie starts having pacing
issues as it kind of starts to slow down
a little too much for me and beyond that
there is world building in here that at
times feels a little unnatural feels a
little too outlandish a bit too big
there's a little too bit a little too
fantastical I think one of the things
that is cool is having some mysticism in
this move
you know calling John wick the bogeyman
yeah but it's one thing for humans to
perceive some mysticism and fantasy it's
another thing for this movie to start
having things that just turn into
fantasy my way of a saying doesn't feel
natural it didn't feel like when they
did the first John wick that they have
this giant world and all these intricate
rules and everything established in all
this history really built and then
they're like okay but when we do sequels
we'll reveal more it feels like when
they make these sequels they're coming
up with more stuff as opposed to
revealing more stuff hopefully you guys
get what I'm going out with that it
doesn't always necessarily feel
essential sometimes things feel like
John wick isms after a while I don't
know it's kind of hard to quantify
because it's all made up so what are the
rules but there are just certain
elements that maybe don't always jell
completely or that will make you start
to wonder about details from previously
in the film or you know what the yeah
the rules are or what the capabilities
of the high table are are different
things like that compared to a lot of
movies this these films all three do a
really great job of paying attention to
their story their characters and their
world but now that we've come this far
I do think that they could do a slightly
better job of supporting the
world-building with story or character
elements beyond the fights and stuff
like that and a way to get to you know
different interesting yeah some people
say like oh you know what this kind of
film the story doesn't really matter as
much but they made it matter than the
very first one I can't I can't get on
board with that
point of view can I sit back and just
enjoy the action when it's occurring and
really fall in love with the sequences
yeah I can't do I really like this movie
yes after loving the first John wick for
being a near-perfect movie having great
character amazing effective storytelling
where the action supports that now it
kind of feels opposite I think the world
for me could use just a bit of
temperance I guess some some kind of
contrast because a little yeah a little
too cheesy there are times during I
think everybody's gonna have a different
line with this movie they've earned the
chance to indulge a little bit I won't
begrudge than that but I think
everybody's gonna have a certain aspect
that maple
their boundaries a little bit in terms
of how big you're willing to allow your
disbelief to be suspended and that's
sort of something about this movie that
I think kind of again meets sort of
halfway it's like I don't think the plot
only exists to figure out how to get
more action in there I think that the
action fits naturally into the world
yeah you know it is the language of
these people and one of the better
elements the more lived-in elements of
this movie is the way that the side
characters kind of reveal how they feel
about that but yeah I feel like they
could just do a better job of delegating
the story elements around yet to really
justify the ways in which they're
expanding beyond just having you know
another cool character show up I would
want to talk a little bit about the John
wick motivation to keep on living after
all this it did get to a point in my
head who were like this guy just died
with everything that's going on links
he's having to go to this dude
specifically what did he just want to
die what does he have to live for and
then the movie goes out of its way to
have a moment a very specific scene to
clearly exposition release state why he
wants to live which is a compelling
question for for John wick movie at this
stage in the game what what does he have
to live for I was okay with the choice
until like 15 minutes later when they
can the choices like I guess my other
little complaint is the way it ends I
felt that this movie could have ended in
a way where we could have a sequel but
this could also be the ending this movie
kind of has a little too much cheese to
its ending and it's so heavy sequels
very much segues it doesn't feel like a
complete movie now yeah and and not that
you have to you know mark a movement
done at 3 or whatever but 3 does feel
like a nice crisp number 2 maybe at
least put a definite act break into your
franchise or something I would have
preferred a movie with a more finite and
a more satisfying ending Keanu Reeves
really throws down for these I'm sure he
would come back again but I don't know
for how long he can do them for part of
the satisfying wait it's like is this
gonna become saw you know after a while
are we gonna keep doing the completely
serialized movie series where every
movie is just okay how does John wick
find his way out of this next one you
know which
far has worked well but yeah I would
have been a bit more satisfied
emotionally as a viewer for the things
this movie confronts the deepest parts
of John Wick's motivation and his will
and ability to stay alive I would have
liked some kind of finite note to end on
I feel like we've brought up a lot of
issues because this movie has just
gotten a heap ton of praise and it
deserves a ton of it ultimately it does
a lot of things really well it does pay
attention to its story it does make some
really cool additions to its world at
the end of the day what you go to show
up for for this movie primarily even for
myself as someone who's so heavily
invested in the first story of this
franchise
I really do go to show up for the action
scenes yeah yeah that's what I really
wanted like that's that's the big WOW
and takeaway factor they really do
deliver and there's a lot of good in
between stuff as well yeah it's just the
the storytelling stuff that didn't work
for me kind of really stood out well I
think it stands out just partly because
they get so very close because to me
this is one of those movies where yeah I
do have a fair amount of nitpicks but
it's all things that could just use
smoothing out like there's no idea or
quality this movie has that I don't
think had a good idea in mind you know a
good place in its heart everything here
belongs it's just I could use a little
more finesse this is a great time isn't
amazing and if you love action you're
gonna like literally every single action
scene this is the first time I think
I've heard I've seen a fight scene where
the audience wanted to break into
applause a few different times before it
ended so that says something to you
alright guys well do you see john waite
chapter 3 do you want more John wick in
your life do you think it should end
comment below subscribe to the rejects
click that notification bell and
download false and start us at see you
guys